[Musique]
bb jacob veut sortir
fanny et david sont tout excités ils se
précipitent à l'hôpital l'employé à
l'accueil demande à david stéphanie veut
une chambre privée
david et surya on lui a toujours dit
qu'il n'y avait que des chambres privées
au pavillon des naissances de cet
hôpital
alors pourquoi poser cette question et
il ne prend pas de risque et répond oui
de retour à la maison la petite famille
reçoit une enveloppe de l'hôpital
mauvaise surprise c'est une facture 400
$ pour la chambre privée
pourtant selon la loi lorsqu'il n'ya que
des chambres privées elles doivent être
gratuite puisque les patients n'ont pas
le choix david fulmine il téléphone à
l'hôpital on lui explique que c'est
parce qu'il a demandé une chambre privée
qu'il doit la payer
s'il avait répondu non il n'aurait pas
eu à payer
david est tombé dans le piège que lui a
tendu l'hôpital le fin mot de l'histoire
les hôpitaux ne s'intéresse pas
seulement à votre santé il re l'udc ou
si votre porte-monnaie